sherlock holmes faire dans les forces de
nos jobs à part pour celui que vous
venez de passer d'un sherlock noces j'ai
les mêmes jardin c'est la fête nautique
commence à disparaître
juliette les autres ils sont tous
disparu il n'y en a qu'un qui peut mener
l'outlet meken appétit je suis choqué je
vous aiderai à les retrouver par
l'organisateur de kung fu panda
nous devons le fondre dans la foule
passer totalement de trois partez vous
êtes prêts on est prêt vous savez ce
qu'il faut faire
l'incroyable aventure quelque chose j'ai
mal au coeur pour toute la famille
d'abord en avant stop nous sommes
repérés
kerloc'h qui nomme aucun écureuils se
trémousse de la sorte les amis c'est
plus une démonstration
[Musique]
au cinéma le 11 avril